We enlisted the help of the great chef
and New York Times Best Selling author
and Queer Eye star Antoni Porowski.
(audience claps and cheers)
Who is just so beautiful on the inside and the outside
and he showed me around his Brooklyn.
And it was really incredible.
Please take a look at this tour.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody I am here in the borough of Brooklyn
and I'm about to be taken on the foodie tour
with a total cutie, it's Antoni Porowski.
And look, he has a brand new cook book.
It's called Let's Do Dinner.
It's so nice to meet you.
Oh my gosh it's so nice to meet you too.
Is this where our love story begins in a polish restaurant
Maybe it does.
Today you're gonna take me
and start the tour at Christina's.
Hm
Why did you pick this place?
My family comes from Poland.
It was the first language that I learned,
I went to Polish school every Saturday.
I still strongly identify with that part of me
and I lived in Brooklyn for like eight plus years
and like this was my hood.
(Antoni speaks foreign language)
Take me inside
Let's go, let's go.
(upbeat Music)
Can we talk about the food a little bit?
Yes, I want you to tell me everything.
First we have borscht, Polish borscht is like a
clear consomme, and then inside you have uszka,
which means tiny ears.
So they're like baby perogies
and they look like little tortellini.
So nice and tart. You can taste the beets.
Ok, I'm going to try one of these.
These are so nice. Go for it, beautiful,
so as you're tasting this,
the meat is not your packaged ground beef.
There is something about the grinder
that kind of turns it into almost
like a pâté-like consistency, and it just melts.
This is a very unique approach
to the meat as you're saying.
I also really wanna compliment you
on your shopping list, for your cookbook.
Oh
Every ingredient resonated,
every ingredient goes well together.
With Let's Do Dinner,
co-author Mindy and I really wanted to make sure,
like there are a lot of ingredients that are repetitive,
but it's like, I love to have my pantry staples
and my things that are there,
so when I go to the store,
I'm looking for my protein,
I'm looking for a vegetable or two, and maybe an herb.
I think for the home cook, that's what we need,
is an unintimidating road map to confidence.
A hundred percent.
So, where are we going next?
It's called Peter Pan,
and they put honey in some of their glaze for their donuts.
I love all things honey.
They put it in everything.
All right, let's go to the next place.
Should we go?
We have to have a treat.
It's also what life is all about.
Totally!
(Upbeat music)
I'm not like the biggest red velvet fan,
but their donut is fantastic.
Blueberry, which they're very famous for.
Nice little pop of sweetness
and then of course your favorite, the honey.
Which one do we want to try first?
The honey
Yeah, cheers.
Oh my god, I do taste the honey too.
It's perfect,
it's the most ridiculous thing I've ever said but,
I wanna lick it, that's the like,
it's bringing me to that point.
Yeah sure.
Oh, yeah yeah yeah.
I just said it's nice.
Me too, it was good, worth it.
I've been trying to make a reservation at Lilia's
for the past year, and I haven't been able to,
so I'm using your star power to get us in today.
(both laugh)
To go have um a lunch after desert. If that's OK?
Well, what's so crazy is Missy Robbins
is on of my idols and I've never been to Lilia.
So you and I are gonna go be Lilia de-virginized.
(Upbeat music)
What do we try first?
We get to experience this together
You pick
as Lilia's virgins.
That's right.
I think we should try.
The oreganata, okay.
Cheers
Really nice heat.
Oh, that's lovely.
Our first, missy pasta.
(Antoni laughs)
I'm so excited, you're going sun dried tomato,
right on there.
I'm going pure, cheers.
I love saffron, look at the saffron bleeding into butter.
The cheese is sort of like a really gentle sheep cheese.
The tomatoes are so nice and sweet too.
If pasta like was on an award system,
this would be the academy award and the Espy's
and the Golden Globe.
And the Catapalm door
I just wanna thank you
because I've come to New York my whole life
but I never felt truly at home here,
and now this is really where I live.
So, it means a lot and I'm very grateful
that you would take me through this borough
and show me your city.
I also think when I lay my head down on the pillow tonight.
I'm gonna be going back to Peter Pan Donuts and Christina's.
Aren't we all?
But in all seriousness, when you asked me
to show you a tour of Brooklyn,
like this was such an important place to me.
I always kind of look at my life like pre queer eye
and post queer eye and as grateful as I am,
I miss part of my old life
and to be able to like experience it with somebody
and like walk down that street that I used to walk down on.
In a way I've been able to kind
of like re-live those feelings.
Yeah
So it was so nice to do.
Will you please take us out of this segment
in Polish please, 'cause I love when you speak it.
(Speaking in Polish)
(audience applause)
Thank you Antoni, I will never forget that food,
that experience, that awesome deep talk we had
and you can pick up his cook book, Let's Do Dinner,
right now and you can get started
with trying some of Antoni's recipes,
everyone in our audience is going home
with a $200 gift card courtesy of OXO.
(audience cheers and applause)
And, you can pick up, I know, I love this company so much.
You can bake, you can pick up thoughtfully designed cooking,
tools, storage, organizations and I love this company
and I know you do already so cheers OXO,
thank you.
(upbeat music)